remember you opened for guns and roses
it was metallica and guns and roses
don't you think it was a huge mistake on
their part
guns and roses i mean to have metallica
open up for them
because you guys go out there and bam
[ __ ]
kill it's i mean we were yeah we were
we were given because the whole premise
of the tour was
you know two best friends two best you
know bands that
love and respect each other and that are
pals let's go out of
summer and we had records that were both
breaking and
let's go out we'll sort of co-headline
we'll play the same length
sets i think we've played each two and a
half hours
uh you know we'll split the dough we'll
we'll do all that stuff i mean it was
50 50 down the line on everything but
obviously
somebody had to go on before we had
faith no more open
some shows motorhead open and body count
open some shows but somebody had to go
on before
the other you know so we're like listen
we don't have to think about that more
than a nanosecond we're happy to go on
so we can go on earlier in the evening
and then
after the show after we're done playing
grab a beer and kick back and watch guns
and roses so that was like a no-brainer
to me it's
it's just crazy because the audience was
exhausted afterwards
and completely satisfied it was a long
night for
i mean it was a long and hopefully a
special night and a
you know but by the time everything was
all said and done it was probably seven
eight hours by the time yeah you had
motorhead uh you know play and and so on
listen the reason that tour happened to
begin with
you know when when guns broke
actually i'll tell you before guns broke
i remember
getting an advanced tape of the album
you know two three months before and
putting it on
and going holy [ __ ] that's a lot of
attitude
you know he comes out in in the second
song it's so easy and every other word
it's so [ __ ] easy and
all that stuff i mean there wasn't a lot
of that around at that time
and just the attitude and the vibe kind
of oozed out of it
and and we befriended them when we were
in la
and got to know each other and and hang
and became pals and the reason
we went on tour together was because we
were pals and then
it's sort of unfortunately for a year or
two after that tour
there was too much of that rivalry it
was a little egged on by the press and
and it was sort of like yo dude people
had to take a side but at heart of it
were two bands that really respected
each other and
liked each other and wanted to spend the
summer together
and um so when i look back on it i
choose to look back on it
like that and and it was definitely one
of the most fundamental summers i've
ever had